It says, "I will never, ever search for any information online
if I would be embarrassed if seen by Grandma Dawnie."
(Laughter)
Try it. It's really effective.
Throughout history,
there has always been a trade-off between liberty and equality
in the pursuit of prosperity.
The world has constantly been going through the circle of wealth accumulation
to wealth redistribution.
As the tension between the haves and have-nots
is breaking so many countries,
it is in everyone's interest,
including the large data companies,
to prevent this new form of inequality.
Of course, individual data ownership is not the perfect nor the complete answer
to this profoundly complex question
of what makes a good digital society.
But according to McKinsey,
AI will add 13 trillion US dollars of economic output in the next 10 years.
Data generated by individuals will no doubt contribute
to this enormous growth.
Shouldn't we at least consider an economic model
that empowers the people?
And if private ownership helped to lift more than 850 million people
out of poverty,
it is our duty
and we owe it to future generations
to create a more inclusive AI economy
that will empower the people in addition to businesses.
Thank you.
(Applause)